και ότν κάμει την υποδομή να έχι ταπειτηση και να ππρώξει των κόσμο να να
ακολουθήσει τη νέαν υποδομήτω νέον τρόπο διακίνησης αλλά πρότατα κάμουμε και μετά να έχουμε να
πει τη συμο κόσμο να τα ακολουθούν πως είναι καθυμένω να το αντρεναβια πάει τον
γυρώ του το προίστη λάρναγανακούση λία παράποτο μετά να πα ένα π πάει στογρα φείο
ταξει ώραι αυτά προείμ γραφείου αρίσκιμο το προινώ να ν ποιο καέμουν και να ποογραφείον
και και πστηά να καακι δηλάνε να καθερμινα διαδή ιτώραμε τον το αύροϊέριμο μεταμέσα κοινωνικής
δικτύωσης μεταο αφοως πριν να φίσε που σπήρει ξέρεις και που είχεάξετε και που έθπασε
ενο θέλα απω ότι σίουρα ι καθυμεροήτα που προβλέπει εκληρώσει σ επισκέψεις μέρω σης καθυμερονιτα
μός αλλά θρα απ ότι και το γραφίουμο και εν κλειστην πόρτα όπως στα εξωτερικά
ι ατρία δηλαδή που το προσωπικώ του κόσμο που τον κόσμο άρα σε συνέχειγρίορση επδικώ
ταοε των κλίσιμο και συζητούσα θέμα συζήι στις τελευτές μέρες ιδατικό όλοι δημάρχει όλιω αντιμετοπίζουν
το δίον πρόβλημα ανησυχίες δικά οι παραλεακές πόλις μεταξυνοδοχία με τον τουρισμό θα μην υπάρξουνα
αποκοπές ο δήμος λάνα γαςφοβάται κια την καλογενητά κενώ συνομιρτα σε με τον πρόεδρον το
εο τω φιλοντωνάγγελον και γενικότερα η γενα ερωνώ ενώπου ενημερώθηκα για τη καρά στηςσυν δική
μας δεν υπάρχει αυτέσει ο κινηδυνόςτων περικοπόνακάμει και μέρα να κοίνο συνο πρόδροση το ιγό
καμ κι να φτιγμάκι το οποίοανακίνωση ναλλά εγώ είμαι κι που λέει και ος πρώτες
τες ενοσιζδίμω ότι μαύροήερημη χώρα εμπολλά ενι εγώ έτσι εγω άλλος πως είμαστε μια στα
για του πω άρα θέλω απω ότι εκαι πιδ ειάγεμένα ενώ μέθαθα γοπίε στην τάρ
να κ επρέπει έχω μια αντηλεμεσόν την πάφωνή εκάτω νώ δέκάχειλε μετρα πιο υπρο εναι
ένα θέμα τα το ποίο μαθα βασχολή όλους το οίο πρέπε αλήσουμ άρα έναι εγώ
έγκυρα πίσω γιατί